first we start with breaking news out of
Maine tonight where we are tracking a
developing situation near the home of
Robert card he's the suspected Mass
shooter responsible for at least 18
murders 13 injured here now at the very
latest she's on the ground she's in main
for us tonight Molly line has uh the
latest on this Molly thanks for being
with
us Sean thanks for having me tonight as
you mentioned the man hunt continues uh
there's a significant amount of activity
in the uh suspect's hometown of Bowden
they've really focused in on a group of
properties on on Meadows Road and then
the last couple hours we've seen
Choppers overhead in that road and a
search warrant being executed there at
that property a law enforcement on a
megaphone uh yelling for quite some time
uh calling for Robert or anyone in that
home uh to come on out to come out
peacefully per main State Police those
announcements that were heard over that
loudspeaker megaphone or just standard
search warrant announcements when
they're executing a search warrant to
ensure the safety of everyone involved
it's unknown
whether Robert card is in any of the
homes that law enforcement is looking to
search over there law enforcement
officials simply doing their due
diligence tracking down every lead and
those properties are associated with
this suspect so they're doing uh
everything they can to find out what
sort of Clues they might be able to draw
from that area they did also use a
series of fast flashbangs earlier uh in
the evening once again uh another uh
tactic an intention to draw out this
suspect if he is there not necessarily
any proof that he actually was
uh things unfolded yesterday just a
little bit before 7:00 Leon Police
responding to those two mass shooting
incidents one in a bowling alley another
at a a bar and Billiard Hall uh by 10:25
in the evening uh Andre scen County
officials had called a countywide
shelter in place order even now
authorities are still asking people to
stay in their homes and lcon police
originally uh calling Robert C A Person
of Interest he is now clearly a suspect
in this homicide mass murder case the
Coast Guard worth noting also involved
now they were up in the sky earlier
today over Booth Bay Harbor uh that's uh
notably because the Subaru the vehicle
that is associated with this suspect was
found in a community uh called Lisbon
not so far from here about a 10-minute
drive from Lewiston uh and there's a
river there and this suspect is known to
have some familiarity uh with boats and
also with weapons as well an internal
law enforcement communication revealing
uh that this individual is a Firearms
instructor a member of the army reserves
and that over the summer uh had been
suffering an escalating Mental Health
crisis essentially ended up being
committed for a series of weeks and
getting treatment uh so that speaks to
potentially how dangerous this
individual really may be law enforcement
officials are warning the public that he
is armed and dangerous and right now uh
they are still running down every a lot
of different agencies involved in this
Sean all right moling lme uh thank you
for that report stay with us we'll be
back hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else